okay our voicemail number is two one
nine two david p here is a really really
good question from a viewer that we've
sort of talked about a little bit but
not in these terms take a listen
hey David this is Andy
good show I'm just wondering what are
the issues that if someone calls you and
asks you for your opinion your position
what are those issues that you're not as
confident on that you're still thinking
through you always have such confidence
in your responses there's got to be some
things that you haven't figured out yet
let me know thanks yeah so listen number
one when someone calls in and of course
our calls aren't pre-screened when
someone calls in and asked me for my
opinion about something that I haven't
seen or I'm not familiar with I just say
I don't know enough about that's a
comment that's not really that's not
really my issue I was once invited to
debate a gentleman a British gentleman
named Carl Benjamin you might know him
as sargon of akkad about the topic of
brexit and I said I am NOT an expert in
brexit I'm not someone who should be
debating anybody about brexit we covered
it in the context of the world economy
and its relationship to American
politics and how it fits into so the
sort of nationalism movements that we've
seen but I don't know enough about
brexit I live in the United States I
don't have any connection to the UK and
I'm simply not an expert on that issue
when people call in and say what do I
think about the conflict in in Kashmir
for example I just don't know enough
about it and I am not ashamed to say
that and I think that that's something
that that should be way more acceptable
none of us can be experts in everything
and it should be fine to say that now in
terms of what issues am i less confident
on certainly there are issues relating
to Asian politics that I know very very
little about there are lots of countries
that are important geopolitically whose
internal conflicts I really don't know
about and I am I just say I don't know
about that I'm not the right person to
ask when it comes to
the dynamics of I don't know what else
there there are certain religious
conflicts that I am NOT well versed
enough in and I wouldn't dream of
imposing my opinion on the audience as
if it's something I know about so my
approach is number one for most of us
most topics were not experts in and
number two it should be okay just to say
that and in fact it should be praised
when we recognize that we don't know
enough about something to comment in an
informed way that should actually be
stigmatized it should be okay to say
that and we should say that's great
let's either learn more or go to the
experts on that issue we've got a great
bonus show for you today I'm out of time
to tell you what's on it but it's a
really good one maybe the best one this
week so far and I look forward to
speaking to you then